coverage of the ongoing conflict in
israel has featured recurring images
like this
missiles streaming across the sky and
exploding mid-air
these are missiles from israel's iron
dome missile defense system
a land-based system that intercepts and
destroys short-range rockets and mortars
[Applause]
it has become a bedrock of the country's
defense since its introduction in 2011.
and in the current round of hostilities
israel's military said the system has
intercepted more than 200
of the more than 1 000 rockets fired
towards israel as of may 12th
here's how the complex detection and
interception system works
the system is powered by missile defense
batteries each containing
three main components these batteries
can defend across short-range rocket and
mortar attacks within almost 45 miles of
the battery
they are also mobile so they can be
moved to where they are needed
first a radar unit detects an incoming
rocket and relays information about its
speed and trajectory to the battery's
control center
the control center's computers calculate
if the rocket is going to hit
populated areas if it is a missile is
fired from the launcher
each launcher contains 20 interceptor
missiles
each receives constant guidance updates
from the control center and its internal
radar
the missile destroys the incoming rocket
by exploding near it
the goal is to do this far away from
populated areas
minimizing damage on the ground the
defense system has intercepted over 2
400 rockets bound for civilian areas
since its launch in 2011
according to an israeli military
spokesperson during a conflict in 2012
the iron dome knocked down 421 rockets
launched from gaza
and bound for israeli cities before a
november ceasefire
and during the 2014 war in gaza it
intercepted 700 rockets fired by
islamist movement hamas
a 90 success rate that effectively
blunted the palestinian group's aerial
threat
the united states has provided hundreds
of millions of dollars in funding for
the system
and has also bought and is testing two
iron dome
batteries of its own and israel has
expanded the defense system by
installing missile batteries on ships
and the system is in the midst of being
upgraded to combat the threat posed by
unmanned drones
as the current conflict continues so
will the use of the iron dome